we begin with this a ruling in a
landmark legal case over the opioid
crisis could lead to one of the biggest
monetary awards in US history
a judge in Oklahoma will decide later
today if Johnson & Johnson bears
responsibility for helping to fuel the
state's opioid epidemic by aggressively
marketing painkillers Oklahoma is asking
for 17 point two billion dollars now
this could set a precedent for cases
around the country Omar Villafranca is
outside the courthouse in Norman
Oklahoma with more on this story but
Omar start us with this what's at stake
for the drug industry here a lot
especially since there's cases in other
states as well but this is the first
time a case like this has gone to trial
but obviously it will not be the last
and depending on how a judge rules it
could provide a new strategy for
attorneys on how to hold big
corporations accountable don't buy that
this was a good company in the context
of this case it is not a good company
for weeks the state of Oklahoma has
argued that Johnson & Johnson and its
pharmaceutical subsidiary Janssen helped
create a public nuisance by intensely
marketing opioid painkillers while
downplaying the risk of addiction we
spoke with the state's legal team this
is very personal to all of us my partner
lost a nice to this opioid epidemic
I lost my firstborn son to the opioid
epidemic the 2017 filing named multiple
defendants Purdue Pharma and Tabo
pharmaceuticals settled out of court for
a combined total of 355 million dollars
without admission of wrongdoing but
Johnson & Johnson and its subsidiary
Janssen decided to go to trial
Sabrina's strong is their attorney when
you're right you fight and that's what
you're seeing here we have sympathy for
those who suffer from substance abuse
but Janssen did not cause the opioid
crisis in this country Johnson & Johnson
says its opioid products account for
less than 1% of the Oklahoma market but
the state disputes that they made money
whether they sold their drugs
or when somebody else sold opioids
because they were supplying everybody
else and this 1% thing that's a complete
canard if the judge rules against
Johnson & Johnson the public nuisance
argument that was previously used
successfully to fight Big Tobacco could
possibly be used in opioid lawsuits set
to go to trial in Ohio this fall
thousands of people being addicted to
prescription opioids thousands of people
dying you've got a public nuisance
you've got harm that's occurring both
sides here in Oklahoma say they will
appeal if the judge rules against him
now not only are there cases that were
filed in Ohio there was also new suits
filed last week in West Virginia against
Johnson & Johnson and also Tembo
pharmaceuticals for misrepresenting the
risks of their opioid products Tony all
right Omar thank you a lot at stake here
billions of dollars but also millions of
lives people looking for justice